congratulations meanwhile to tyler perry
who was honored last night at the world
famous apollo theater but the big
headline his new revelations about the
moments after the oscar slap and will
smith's current state of mind
oh wow
wow when we walked over to him he was
devastated he couldn't believe what
happened he couldn't believe he did it
two and a half months after the slap
heard round the world tyler spoke about
it for the first time with gail king at
a tribeca film festival event i left
early to go and check on chris because
it was wrong in no uncertain terms and i
made sure i said that to will
were you comforting him in that i was i
was making sure
there's a difference between comforting
and de-escalating being friends with
both of them has been very difficult
as for will's current state of mind i
think he
is very much in reflection of trying to
figure out what happened
we were with tyler last night at the
apollo theater spring gala where he was
being honored with the impact award this
historic place the
lives the souls the dreams that came
through this place and to be honored
here it's really really amazing i'd like
to give a half million dollars to to
make sure that this place continues to
grow and thrive
miss phylicia rashad and samuel l
jackson were among those in attendance
snl's keenan thompson was mc for the
night he told us in spite of fellow cast
members like kate mckinnon and pete
davidson leaving the show he has no
plans to quit anytime soon if i felt
like i was you know overstaying my
welcome or unwanted then i would like
show myself the door we at least trying
to get to the 50th because that's going
to be a special year you know what i
mean and then
after that it's like i don't know
exactly how long i can do it